i think we're doing exactly what we
intended to do which is come fly the
atlantic uh fly to london and disrupt
things with a better product a better
service and lower fares than the
competition obviously the reopening of
the uk us travel corridor in november
has been a big boost to bookings and we
look forward to connecting more
customers over the holidays and now
you're launching a route to gatwick as
well yeah i mean these are ferociously
competitive routes
they are we just uh launched gatwick
today i actually flew in on our flight
and again i think you know we're
what we do best is is create competitive
change this is a market that
for many years frankly the fares have
been far too high in the service hasn't
been what i think customers deserve and
we've done this in the us time and time
again and we look forward to disrupting
and bringing the jetblue experience and
continuing to bring the jetblue effect
over to um to all of our friends in
england
it's been suggested though that
you start at a disadvantage compared
with the likes of british airways and
virgin atlantic for example they have
lounges in the airports they uh they
have more convenient takeoff and uh
landing times as well
yeah i mean we've definitely faced
challenges around competition and access
to certain airports like heathrow and
gatwick um you know we've got our foot
in the door and we think the more flying
we do we can demonstrate um why it's
important to have new entrant carriers
like jetblue
be able to have access so that we can
frankly discipline the rest of the
industry and ensure that fares are where
they should be for customers our view is
you shouldn't have to trade a great
service for for a low fare we can do it
both that's what we've done in the
united states and we're going to
continue to do that here we've got a
great onboard product we have
24 suites a single aisle access private
door
in the front of the cabin we've got 114
seats in the back of the cabin 24 of
which have even more legroom we've got
fantastic foods
fantastic drinks
signature cocktails free wi-fi
television amenity kits you name it and
you know i think because we're a smaller
airline we're able to really provide a
very curated residential experience
onboard our aircraft and we think once
customers try us they're going to
realize that
what we do is pretty different pretty
cool and they'll try us again
are you looking to fly into any other uk
airports for example manchester
yeah right now we're focused on london
um we look forward to bringing service
out of boston to london next summer so
that's the next step you'll see and then
we'll take it from there there's a
number of places both in the uk and in
europe that we look forward to serving
um assuming we can get access and we can
get gates and slots in those airports
now it's a busy time for you because
yesterday you announced that you were
paying a billion dollars for a supplier
of sustainable aviation fuel is that is
that business going to just supply you
or will it be supplying competitors as
well
sure i mean we expect over time it will
supply competitors but one of our you
know main goals at jetblue is to
hopefully achieve net zero carbon
emissions this is yet another step
towards that
you know we'll be the leader in
operating flights and sustainable
aviation fuel next year in the u.s
industry
you know we have a goal of 10 percent
sustainable aviation fuel use of our
total fuel purchase by 2020 by 2020 um
2030 and you know we're well on our way
there this will bring us to eight
percent we think sustainable aviation
fuel is the is the past of the future
but frankly we need more supply um so
that can bring prices down to support it
for the industry